حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخره لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفوته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او دفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول ليست متوفره
حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا وتايوان حل
لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه الخجوله قبل
اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي خساره الطرفين
وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات